So we've talked about uh,classification and regression and gave a
couple of examples of each. So now I want you to
take a moment to make certain that you understand the
difference because it's a crucial difference for supervised learning. Here's a
very short little quiz. You have three questions here and
we divided the world up into some input to some learning
algorithm, whatever that learning algorithm is. The output that we're
expecting and then a box for you to tell us whether
its classification or regression. So, the first question, the input is
credit history, whatever that means, the number of loans that you
have, how much money you make, how many times you've defaulted,
how many times you've been late, the sort of things that make
up credit history, and the output of the learning algorithm is
rather you should lend money or not. So you're a bank,
and you're trying to determine whether given a credit history, I
should lend this person money, that's question one. Is that classification, or
is that regression? Question two you take as input
a picture like the examples that we've given before.
And the output of your learning system is going
to be whether this person is of high school age,
college age, or grad student age. The third question is very similar.
The input is again a picture. And the output is, I guess, of the actual
age of the person, 17, 24, 23 and a half, whatever.
So take a moment and try to decide
whether these are classification tasks or regression tasks.